So when it comes to staying informed about
the pandemic, we are getting very different
messages from different messengers.
And we have a new poll that has very quickly
helped told us that Donald Trump is not one
of the most trusted messengers for the American
people, although his approval rating is actually
up.
And I'm going to talk about that seeming incongruity
in a moment.
It may not surprise you that New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo and Dr. Anthony Foushee, who's
one of the top infectious disease experts
in the country, who's been a fixture of at
least some of Trump's press briefings.
They are the most trusted people for guidance
on the pandemic.
And the poll asked, when it comes to official
advice regarding Corona virus, please rate
how much you trust the following messengers
on a scale from 1 to 5.
Of course, a higher number being more trusted.
Dr. Anthony Foushee at the top at 3.8 for
followed by Andrew Cuomo at 3.2 9.
Dr. Deborah Burke's close behind at 3.1.
Democratic California Governor Gavin Newsome
at 2.9 7, followed by Joe Biden, then Mike
Pence.
And Donald Trump is trusted only more than
Stephen Manoogian.
So it looks to put it a different way.
Only Stephen Manoogian is less trusted when
it comes to coronavirus than Donald Trump.
So I have a few different thoughts on this.
So on the one hand, there's no question that,
of course, Foushee and Cuomo are more trustworthy
than Donald Trump.
That's the reality.
It's good that the polls reflect that.
The other side of it is, though, the numbers
should be far more stark.
I mean, the degree to which Anthony Foushee
and Andrew Cuomo present facts and live in
the real world compared to the degree with
which Donald Trump is living in a fantasy
world with just lies and distortions.
You would hope that the numbers were more
than you know.
One point, something points apart.
But let me talk about the other side of this
for a second, because Donald Trump's approval
rating is up.
The portion of the population that believes
Donald Trump is handling Corona virus properly
is quite high.
It's much higher than anyone who's been paying
attention in a real way would expect it to
be.
And so it seems like there's a disconnect
there.
How can Donald Trump be so not trusted when
it comes to the specifics of coronavirus,
while at the same time he's got the highest
approval rating of his presidency, or at least
tied with the highest approval rating of his
presidency?
I don't think there is as much of a disconnect
there as some people might think.
Here's what's going on.
It appears that on the facts, most Americans
realize what Donald Trump says about the virus
is not accurate.
He's either lying, he's incompetent.
He doesn't know he's being deceptive.
But at the same time that Americans recognize
that, we know that during national crises
there is a degree of a rally around the president
effect.
It's only a few points of approval that Donald
Trump has gained, and that's probably what
explains it.
Trump, because of the rally around the president
mentality during a crisis, in this case, a
pandemic has gained a little bit of approval
there.
But on the facts, Americans realize that the
guy is a buffoon when it comes to coronavirus.
Now, there's another issue that's probably
a factor in the United States.
We've got very densely populated areas and
very rural depopulated areas.
Right now, it's much more the densely populated
areas that are having the corona virus cases
and the deaths.
So there are probably lots of people who are
saying, I'm not seeing many cases in my area.
I don't know of anybody who's got it.
I'm not hearing about death.
So therefore, Donald Trump must be handling
this well while simultaneously realizing when
they hear Trump speak that on the facts of
the day to day, he probably can't be trusted.
Now, when it comes to Dr. Foushee, there are
more and more questions about how long he's
going to be allowed to have a public presence
because he doesn't seem completely onboard
with every idiotic thing that Donald Trump
says.
Although there's some limit to how much he
can express that that disagreement publicly,
there is no doubt that despite Donald Trump
saying two days ago when he was asked, is
everything okay with you and Dr. Foushee,
he said, of course, of course, of course.
My if I found out in a few days that Foushee
was gone or resigned, it would not be a huge
surprise.
I'm not saying I expect it to happen, but
it would not be surprising.
Could be a combination of, you know, Trump
gets very jealous.
People seem to like and trust Dr. Foushee
much more as we see from this poll.
Trump's not going to like that.
Additionally, Dr. Foushee, I can't imagine,
is going to say let's let her rip on April
12.
That could create a point of conflict.
It wouldn't be shocking to me if we never
see Dr. Foushee again, at least with Donald
Trump.
After a few days.
Lastly, let me talk about Donald Trump's daily
press conferences.
There is a growing debate over whether corporate
media should, should or shouldn't cover the
daily coronavirus press conferences from Donald
Trump, because on the one hand.
Donald Trump is using them to spread disinformation.
He's telling lies, he's cheerleading his handling
of Corona virus.
On the other hand, it is the president speaking
about a national emergency and a pandemic.
So what what should corporate media do?
So this is not to pat myself on the back because
lots of people are doing this.
What corporate media should do is to in real
time, fact check Donald Trump.
You've got to be ready when Trump says things
about testing.
We've tested more people than anyone we say.
We have three hundred and forty million people
on a per capita basis.
That's not true.
And that's what matters.
When Donald Trump says GM is making ventilators,
we point out and we say no, GM is making a
list of parts they would need and figuring
out where they would get the parts.
That's what GM has done so far.
GM is not making ventilators.
I don't know that corporate media is willing
to do it because they will take heat from
the right if they do that.
That would be the responsible way to cover
Donald Trump's press conferences and publicly
push for Trump not to be a part of them.
Say we just want to hear from the doctors
and the public health experts.
That's what they should do.
I wouldn't expect them to do it.